here's how shenzhen works you put up a
dam things are going well here's
skyscrapers and then you put up another
one right next to it because you can and
then to really drive the point home you
do all of this next to a metallurgic
marvel of a stadium we're talking about
a boom town the likes of which the world
has never seen before
[Music]
and things are just getting started
because inside the big stadium is the
real action
[Music]
it's a scene of smarts creativity and
hustle being collectively main life
[Music]
it doesn't look pretty it doesn't smell
great it might even be inhumane but all
of this is aimed at making China the
dominant technology force of the future
[Music]
and Silicon Valley should be very very
afraid
welcome friends to Robo masters
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a robotics competition that
draws in hundreds of engineering
students from around the world as you'll
soon see I don't really understand the
intricacies of the games but the gist is
that you build some robots choosing from
six different types like the engineer
which heals other BOTS or the hero which
does extra damage then you put them in a
stadium and have them fire plastic
bullets at each other to score points
it's fun for the whole family
if your family is a bunch of insanely
competitive gearheads
[Applause]
[Music]
four contestants this can be an intense
experience what's your life been like
for the last week the average baking
time there's like three or four hours
how do you do it every day and keep
doing that for weeks it's crazy what's
these kids arrived for the competition
they basically don't leave the stadium
for two weeks in fighting robot battle
after robot battle takes its toll
when was the last time you had something
to eat yesterday you have a Deans event
but it's all worth it because the reward
if you're lucky is a job a DJ I the
sponsors of the competition in the
world's top maker of drone
if you're a talented young roboticist
coming here to Shenzhen to work at DJI
is the dream so the stakes are high
there are plenty of Chinese tech
companies that produce nothing but cheap
knockoffs DJI is not one of them the
company was started in 2006 by a college
student named Frank Wang he made
components for drone hobbyists and then
decided to go ahead and make a full-on
drone Empire I think the core value of
DG is we're always trying to innovate
something new for example when we create
a drone they are actually no flying
camera we create is concept of flying
camera that's basically true
DJ eyes first runaway hit the Phantom
brought camera drones to the masses for
the first time in 2012 since then
they've made bigger drones smaller
drones teeny tiny drones and some
specialty ones like this crop dusting
drum
all its products have sold well most of
its major competitors have flown away in
tears the company rakes in billions of
dollars a year and has thousands of
employees all over the world and now
they want to pay it forward our founder
after DJI become a lot of is successful
yeah a little bit yeah he started to
think that it's time to host his own
robotics competition we want engineers
to be recognized as Superstars and as
this competition we hope it becomes very
popular and the people end up being
inspired by this engineer's it's not
just the competition itself there's also
a Robo masters documentary a Robo
masters reality show and even a Robo
masters anime with this media blitz DJI
hopes to foster a new generation of
innovative engineers who can then join
the drone Empire and make it even
stronger or maybe start the next DJI
in other words what we have here is less
of a friendly little robot fest and more
of a plan for world domination looks
like it's up to me to sabotage this
thing does that make me seem scary I've
managed to infiltrate this team from
George Young University this is almost
too easy we're going up against the
University of Washington Chinese teams
usually destroy American lives but my
incompetence should even up the odds you
guys don't shoot me okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
prepare your teas let the robo slaughter
begin
[Music]
now what am I gonna try to do where am I
going after the games don't leave me
are we read or blue
[Music]
are we winning how come nobody's talking
[Music]
we win yes
I couldn't really tell what's happen it
was it close so we kicked your ass thank
you
I'm sorry America I tried a few days
later I returned to the stadium to
witness the final round of competition
it's South China University of
Technology vs. China's Northeastern
University
the winners will take home tens of
thousands of dollars the respect of
their fellow nerds and most likely a job
offer from DJI for another up-and-coming
company
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the future drone makers of the PRC it's
an adrenaline pumping good time here in
Shenzhen but the city's tech revolution
has a dark side as well soon it can
leave factory workers out in the cold
and give rise to the most sophisticated
surveillance state the world has ever
seen
we got its facial recognition it's all
in the system they know where you are
scary we'll plumb those depths next time
on hello world thanks for watching and
if you want to see more hello world
click on the link to subscribe